hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's time for episode 5 in our series
looking at free-to-play games on your
ps4 like usual use the comment section
below to find people to game with and if
you don't like anything on the list then
check out the other 40 games we've
looked at before I'm confident you'll
find at least one game that you love on
this list I'll be scouring the comments
section to find a group to play warframe
with but before I get sidetracked let's
do this let's start with brawlhalla an
online or local platformer fighter which
brings back memories of Smash Bros
supporting up to 8 players in free for
all at first glance brawl Halla looks
like it's for those casual players but
scratch the surface and there's enough
progression and unique moveset - and
look for the most hardcore players each
character has signature abilities stats
weapons and combos so will you play as
all 30 characters or master just one
aspect and spam the same move repeatedly
we all know someone who does that in
case you haven't played a platformer
fighter before the aim of this game is
to beat the opposition into a pulp or
knock them off the platform it's so
simple and can be like that if you want
it to be but the tactical approach and
targeting specific players can make this
one a rage infuse control smashing
experience especially in 8-player games
the speed is absolutely mind-boggling
brawl halo was released back in 2014 but
has only just made it over to the ps4
and already has a large user base
foursome the art style it's a little too
childlike but if you can get past that
you can fill the smash brother sized
void in your life a few months ago I
completely missed the release of Dungeon
Defenders 2 on the ps4 so I'd like to
put that right now Dungeon Defenders 2
is all about saving atheria with a
sizeable cast of 10 quirky characters
it's ultimately a tower defense formula
with waves of attacking enemies over 23
maps and levels the hack and slash
influences are evident here with the
loot system which constantly adds
abilities and items to keep you hooked
if you are into team management then
Dungeon Defenders 2 could be the game
for you oh and the greatest thing in my
eyes is the split-screen support
couch co-op needs games like this as
you'd expect the online multiplayer is
where this
flourishes so throw your psn below and
squad up with other people if you've
been around this channel in recent weeks
you'll know I am absolutely besotted by
for tonight's battle royale mode that
game type is free to play at present and
the others will be free to play next
year the premise of battle royale is
just like the film which I demand you go
and watch if you haven't already it has
school kids murdering one another what
more could you ask for in for tonight's
version of battle royale you take up one
spot in a server of 100 people in the
hopes of being the last man standing
similarly with jewels and squads weapons
and consumables are picked up on-site
usually using a pickaxe to smash through
walls to find luke chests full of
goodies there's a building mechanic -
fortnight allowing you to build huge as
sniper towers and forts each game lasts
less than 20 minutes as the play area
shrinks forcing players together so
expect a lot of gunfights I honestly
can't sing the praises of battle royale
anymore it's such a great game once you
give it a try
I like it so much that I've made it a
regular on this channel if you haven't
got the umbrella for winning yet then
add me on PSN we are more than happy to
help you get your first win
next on the list is the raiders of the
broken planet let's quickly realign
expectations here
this requires PS Plus and is only the
prologue to the game's first campaign it
appears that the devs are hoping you
like the prologue so much that you'll
purchase other stories on the plus side
of this one Raiders has a great
soundtrack an awesome art style epic
cinematic cutscenes and a man's naked
buttocks
let's not stare too long there are
elements of Metal Gear Solid Gears of
War and anything you can think of with
space cowboys frustratingly when I went
to download this in the UK I couldn't
please could you verify that it's
available in your respective countries
I'd be very much obliged
[Music]
warframe may have been one of the first
free-to-play titles on ps4 but the
latest update is so good many people are
calling its warframe - with that in mind
I'm putting it on the list again the
expansion planes of Eidolon is visually
stunning and embraces innovation so if
you disliked it five years ago it may be
time to give it another try there's a
gorgeous new warframe inspired by glass
with new abilities there is a new town
hub a new race of NPCs there's a new
quest system there's a new weapon
crafting system I really could go on
world events introduce a hectic nature
to warfarin and the new area is 9
kilometers squared or as I like to say
[ __ ] huge this open-world area allows
up to 50 players to gather and to do
monumental things like I've just said or
what about to spot a fishing instead as
the night time roles in the enemies are
beefed up with the eidelons who are boss
like creatures who have specific puzzles
to figure out before you can understand
how to destroy them I'm going to jump
into this one later this month and would
like to join a group who will show me
the basics my PSN is at the start and
end of the video so if you can help me
out please let me know thank you very
much in advance also if you have any
noob advice for players who are new to
the concept please help in the comments
depending on when you're watching this
warframe planes of idle on released on
the PC a few weeks ago and is out on ps4
and Xbox one on November the 14th
[Music]
next up is death tale which at present
is in a strange state between open beta
and full release it's an action focused
RPG with a heavy platforming element to
contend with you play as a Reaper who is
trying to save the souls of people who
are close to death the woman of his
dreams well of your dreams is death
herself who gave you immortality after
falling in love with you
death sisters have since enslaved death
and forced her to produce an army to
tirelessly take human lives and plunder
their souls
it sounds pretty lovely doesn't it take
along your trusty scythe and traverse
the land slaying every abomination you
find using combos and your trusty magic
death tail forces you to take the souls
of people you meet for example in one
scenario you are forced to choose
between a mother and an ill child which
is surprisingly hard to balance as young
souls are far more favorable to that of
old ones so ultimately it comes down to
how much of a bastard you are death a
tail will be releasing on the PS Vita
soon which in my opinion suits the
control scheme a little better
have you tried death tail I'd love to
know your thoughts let's give some love
to PSV our users of the world in the
shape of rec room first released on the
HTC vive it is now time for PlayStation
users to try it out as it will be in
open beta status from November the 21st
in rec room you join a virtual reality
social club or Recreation Club if you
prefer this is filled with multiplayer
mini games such as paintballing frisbee
golf and even sure HUDs more will be
added over time so jump in I'll
definitely be trying this one although
the art style is very minimalist there
is customization to allow you to stand
out from the crowd and you can even
decorate your own dorm room the growing
list of activities also includes co-op
quests for up to four players now who's
up for trying that I need to know what
that means rec room could be the new
PlayStation Home for VR users we shall
see I suppose
[Music]
rec room join the funds will free do you
fancy something with a little more death
and destruction how about a military
strategy game
here's guns of in which you fight for
global domination in a side-scrolling
tower defense style recent updates have
introduced new units which vary the
game's options there's a social element
in the shape of alliances allowing us to
compare our stats and to be part of a
bigger team there's a card system blue
boxes and daily rewards which when added
together gives guns up more depth than
you probably expect there's over 1
million active players and although that
doesn't sound like very many compared to
other titles it's a million try counting
to a million and you'll know how
impressive that number is
[Music]
again which I've been asked to bring to
your attention is planetside 2 you may
have kept your distance from this one in
the early years as it struggled to fight
the might of other free-to-play titles
on PlayStation 4 as it has grown its
adapted it's definitely worth looking at
again let's put the basics in place
planetside 2 started out as a
first-person shooter set in an all-out
planet war it's included vehicular
warfare 2 and tactical awareness you'd
expect from something of this scale but
surprisingly those aren't the elements I
want to bring to your attention the
continuous updates are changing
planetside 2 into something quite
breathtaking for example new implants
are released regularly to adapt your
character and play style small things
like the carapace sorry if I butchered
that word which replaces your shield
with an additional health pool or the
ocular shield which subdues the full
match of enemy grenades against you this
level of customization allows you to
build the exact character and play style
you want on top of all this regular
holiday themed events are present with
unique rewards as I'm writing this the
nanite of the Living Dead event returned
which is planetside 2 Halloween event
I'm personally looking for a
free-to-play title and at the moment
it's between planetside 2 and warframe
tough choice what would you pay
we must fight together to survive number
10 on this list is hand of gods smite
tactics I'm sure you've noticed the
success of card based games such as The
Witches Gwent or hearthstone and of
course Magic the Gathering well now it's
time for smite to try its hand at it and
it's a pretty godly hunt as the god you
are your job is to decide which minions
to fight your battles
what's rather impressive is the voice
acting as you learn the basics the story
is far more compelling than I was
expecting the card game itself keeps you
on your toes with different abilities
and passive skills for each card this is
definitely for people who love mythology
and want to see Hades of Zeus fights in
the ultimate very soft the more I look
into this game the more I'm impressed
with it
at present smite tactics requires ps+ to
play but other than that it is a full
free-to-play title always double check
cost before downloading though just
because it's free now doesn't guarantee
it will be in the future so there we go
another 10 video games you can play
right now on your ps4 for free hopefully
there's something for everyone here and
if I've missed any classics please let
me know remember to use the comments to
find other people because social gaming
is what it's all about I imagine from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]